welcome to raising awareness with yami
park today in this video
i am going to explain eight reasons why
the world should fear chinese communist
party
and north korean regime people often
think
kim jong is a problem but
chinese communist party is the actual
problem
chinese communist party funds north
korea
enables north korea and maintains north
korea the way it is
without china north korea can never
survive
on its own even just for one month it
will collapse
right there if china stops help north
korean regime
[Music]
so eight reasons why china is a danger
to
the rest of the world number one china
helps north korea to build
these weapons of mass destruction and it
leads to selling
these missiles in the black markets
these weapons that is going into the
middle east or africa
causes so much human suffering and
severe unrest
number two drug creation and
distribution north korea in the
in early 90s in the lab
the regime ordered is a scientist make
some medicine that keeps the officials
up and can work really hard
without even sleeping what they were
really doing is they're trying to create
these super humans
and in this lab what the scientists came
up with was
thing called crystal meth the regime
gave it to the high of fissures
and this this christian math i never
done it but what it says is that you
don't have to sleep for 24 hours
you become very energetic and you can
pay attention to a lot of
little details this drug initially made
for the officials in north korea to work
hard for the regime later the scientists
in the lab were selling them on the side
to the black market
north korea people started using this
math
and then later it was sort to china and
from china to the rest of the world
there are so many drug overdoses in
america right now
like 75 000 people dying from drug
overdose
chinese communist party kills their own
people to consume drugs
but they don't care that americans die
from these drugs they make in their
lives
they're dumping this mess and other
drugs to into american
society and is taking so many innocent
lives
and we must stop it china also create
these drugs
and sell it to americans they don't care
these drugs destroy american lives
where they execute their own citizens if
they consume drugs
number three china is influencing
censorship in america media is in bed
with the chinese communist party
they get millions of dollars all these
mainstream medias that we consume every
day
are embedded china and they give us the
certain narrative the chinese regime
wants us to see and believe the another
area that censorship is happening
is especially in hollywood the films i
don't know if you have noticed it or not
if you watch
recent hollywood movies there's so much
sentiment
of anti-american especially in hollywood
films
they have been started to demonizing
white people
the heroes are people of colors
or chinese that is how the risk
narrative is changing
in hollywood films furthermore tech
monopolies
are started to censoring our free speech
too they are cooperating with the
chinese communist party
and they are censoring all these
articles of
any conversation that we have that
doesn't fit their narrative
look at twitter look at facebook i mean
every mainstream
social media is not supporting free
speech
and only wants to have one narrative
that is often the chinese regime's
narrative that
want us to talk about next point china
has been funding
many projects especially top
universities
in america this is pretty alarming
because we send our children
to get this higher education but when
they go there
what they learn is anti-american
sentiment
in these universities are filled with
anti-americanism
because they are getting these funds
from china
especially schools like the harvard
japan
and pretty much all these ivy league
schools are getting money from china
and therefore in school i went to one of
the schools myself
and i just couldn't believe it i
couldn't believe this is like the
this is america this is the greatest
country on human
history and they are saying how white
people are the problem
and they have caused the you know every
problem that we have in this world
and this one single narrative is getting
into our young generation's mind
and no wonder why all these young people
are supporting
socialism right now in this today's
world the problem is that
nobody is announcing chinese communist
party especially the mainstream media
or even nbas we saw that the lebron
james
how he was defending the ccp's position
on
over hong kong why so hypocritically he
is talking about black
lives matter in america but obviously
for them
hong kong people's freedom is not matter
to them only person who's been
denouncing the ccp is
trump he's the only president that
actually came out
and talking about the problem that china
is causing to the rest of the world
number five oppression of minority
groups
right now in china there are lots of
concentration camps
and in these camps are the people of
minority groups one of them are vigorous
and a lot of other peoples especially in
tibet
chinese regime identity by and
destroying their culture and language
and
literally everything they took
everything away from tibetans
and now their next target is of course
people in xinjiang
that who wants to be independent from
this chinese communist party
not only these people like myself the
people who
ran away from oppression from north
korea going into china
what chinese regime does is catching us
and send us
back to north korea to be executed or
tortured or sent to prison camp
number six coronavirus this virus came
from
china and china did not even stop it
they created this virus
and caused so much harm and created
new normal for all of us this was just
the beginning
we do not know what is coming next from
china
number seven cyber warfare from north
korea
the future warfare is no longer going to
be using news
it's probably going to happen through
cyberspace
and north korea has been preparing that
all of that warfare
through chinese help north korea is
building these
armies of hackers they've been stealing
so many money from the
individual accounts and been hacking you
know
stealing bitcoins not only that they
were
hacking this insurance company in the uk
and hospitals
literally a lot of things that we are
vulnerable to and
north korean hackers can only do this
job because china is helping them and
north korean hackers having a base in
china right now
and doing this work do you all remember
when the sony studio were hacked by
north koreans
if you say something upsetting to
dictator
north korean regime has a capability to
retaliate what we say
and taking things from us and linking
our personal information
this is an actual threat that north
korea is imposing to
everyone in this world right now on
online lastly
number eight china's social credit
system
doesn't allow chinese people to dissent
right now
china using this ai and facial
recognition technology
to watch literally every citizen
what they do what they say what they
write and they give them
credits to to literally scores every
citizen
based on how royal they are to this
college party
and if your score is low in china right
now
you cannot even take a transportation
you cannot take the train to go see your
parents or your loved ones
you cannot take the airplane and flying
out this is a weird true
oppression that georgia orwell
envisioned in 1984 in his book
that big brother is watching you all the
time and chinese people are being
watched
by chinese communist party every day in
every single move
there is no guarantee that our freedom
is safe from this kind of tyranny i
only covered eight points today but
there are so many other problems
that why china is dangerous to humanity
this was
my message to you today i would love to
hear your thoughts
please comment below and thank you for
watching